I'm here because I was asked to to be
the host of this evening bye miss Lauren
which meant a great deal to me and she's
an incredible person just thinking about
her beauty can keep air traffic
controllers awake at night at brilliant
actress she was also one of the world's
great sex symbols she once said
everything you see I owe to spaghetti
well if that's true Joan Rivers could
have saved herself a lot of money so
tonight we celebrate her career for over
six decades she's shown the world a
woman who was much more than just
gorgeous she can be funny mysterious
dramatic exciting naughty profound
heartbreaking Sophia's proof that talent
whence out because if you have looks but
no talent well then you're on Celebrity
Apprentice the list of her co-stars
reads like a who's who of film history
Cary Grant Clark Gable Sinatra Gregory
Peck Marlon Brando Peter O'Toole Richard
Burton Pauly Shore I was just seeing if
you were paying attention Gerard
Depardieu which is a great Mel Brooks
name Gerard Depardieu some dipa don't
heed applaud else the most frequent
on-camera partner was my cello Mastriani
with whom she made 13 films her most
frequent off-camera partner was me she
is the first performance win an academy
award for role in a language other than
English and yet Arnold Schwarzenegger
has none it's an amazing career and a
life story she grew up in a little
village and in Naples her family faced
hard times during World War two but the
age of about 14 her extraordinary beauty
led her to become a finalist in a beauty
contest which she didn't win who won
this thing
you
you